yeah enter this house
[Music]
ow
[Music]
[Music]
pilot to Bombardier time to go
[ __ ] uncle Joey here and a
beautiful cloudy day to be alive I don't
give a [ __ ] cloudy hurricanes whatever
the [ __ ] you got to be ready for war
[ __ ] from the halls of Montezuma to
the shores of Tripoli you gotta be a
[ __ ] refund Marine and I'm talking
hey no you bad [ __ ] uncle Joey
smoking reefer making plans writing
goals building [ __ ] bridges
are you kidding me or what kindly give a
shout-out to my brothers and sisters out
there in the struggle you bad
[ __ ] from Timmy Holloway jr. -
my man man what a boxer boy you
[ __ ] will be spooking Leon and
[ __ ]
arguing with the UFC all DeLeon's on
their [ __ ] you ever seen them but
then Leon they were supposed to [ __ ]
announce another fight with Ronda before
July you're right yeah everybody for one
who gives a [ __ ] about the UFC we're
talking about Wednesday [ __ ] and now
you're gonna go out there and get your
dick sucked you smell it smells like
Jerusalem
you understand me that means you better
walk that get you a knife in your
[ __ ] quite honest songs and go out
there put on your dick you understand
that got a crown of thorns on my dick
that's how I roll [ __ ] that's how
deep my pain those but I don't give a
[ __ ] you gotta get out there and [ __ ]
make it happen cuz it man ain't nobody
gonna make it out before you what if is
gonna make it happen who could do it you
could do that whoo whoo
nobody have you little smoothie a banana
maybe some [ __ ] an egg get some wheat
toast the [ __ ] house making it happen
I got a bunch of [ __ ] going on but I
can't even stop today I don't even stop
53i team is stumped and I gotta go bad
or boom talk to this guy get might buy
this [ __ ] Corinthian you know three
o'clock we got a podcast and that's it
Sacramento tomorrow [ __ ] night are
you kidding me
what's his if baby this is it you want
me to lie to you tell you I'm making a
tab of shade I'm ready for war I need to
count when you're ready for [ __ ] war
I got my dick and two balls they're
filled with [ __ ] care another
nutrients of debt no [ __ ] out of my face
is it my brother Dale
uncle Joey love you sure but that's it
you gotta make it happen you have to
walk there to lay with the baseball bat
and tell these [ __ ] hey I'm
getting my lunchbox back because I [ __ ]
the door people to see so I feel bad for
you but you're [ __ ] over you were
[ __ ] thinkin cuz I know what the [ __ ]
I'm thinkin got a nice Jew drill class
today I had a regular class but burn
some calories
I think I'll talk to some people I'm
doing this podcast and I gotta [ __ ]
get dressed again I go talk to sis other
[ __ ] guy about watches I'd make more
money as a [ __ ] yeah but I'm here I'm
here fight these [ __ ] and I
suggest you do the same you understand
me once I smoke down that means the
river
he's hitting my cranium but hey you
don't save me [ __ ] [ __ ] with the one
one more out of respect for the soldiers
wrong with us
I don't know fussing I said ooh no tiene
que may take poet laureate recomment mo
idiot
the delicate anomaly in the vinegar is
Eloy and to move bad boy in Hawaii run
or Pisarenko you so evil as an easy
mahalia and Polly do back muharram mm um
and the painter vom Hitler sorry about
that
I got my little stick momentum gone i
canna stop that's what the reefer
destiny but [ __ ] let's do one more
let's do what do you have to do in life
I gotta listen to some boss
easy-listening some [ __ ] [ __ ] talking
about whatever he job gives a [ __ ]
Uncle Joe
you know us baby happy [ __ ] Nui every
day every day fill this one up good
there's an earthquake I can't take it
abandon ship
okay
I was a big hit
I gotta stop blowing this doctor police
exercise in the morning before [ __ ] this
mocha number anyway who loves you more
than me [ __ ]
you know nobody I'm here backing down on
the radio airwaves
now cut out will you start the [ __ ]
day on the right foot the only thing
that's better than Mays [ __ ] coward
shillings a that's the audience better
luck with Joey in the morning his
[ __ ] cowards everything else is
elementary anyway go out there [ __ ]
these [ __ ] up tell him uncle
Joey sent you I love you see it three
o'clock
well la pinga Glen throw la la la you
know mmm if somebody shoots you your
dick will attract the metal that's how
bad of a [ __ ] you are today
remember that will not being down and
then throw lalala I love you guys keep
guys open the everywhere stop looking
like your [ __ ] phone like the rest of
these [ __ ] Gentiles stay black